from the river to the sea from The River
To The Sea paltin will be green paltin
will be green is under attack what do we
do anti-Semitism erupting again on
college campuses right now students in
dozens of schools are ditching class for
an anti-israel National walk out the
brainwashed radicals are calling for an
immediate ceasefire and end of American
Aid to Israel that's on top of the
disgusting display at George Washington
University students there using a
projector to display pramas messages on
the school's library messages that read
quote your tuition is funding genocide
in Gaza another says quote the blood of
Palestinians is on your hands and the
most disturbing sign said glory to our
Martyrs but these left-wing agitators
should keep in mind their will be
consequences the NYU student who lost a
lucrative job offer after writing that
Israel Bears full responsibility after
the Hamas attack is doubling down I will
continue to speak up for Palestinian
human rights and use whatever platform I
have available to me to call for a
ceasefire and you know in this
occupation that's harming the
Palestinians do you condemn hamas's
actions on October 7th I think what I
use my platform for and who I Dem was
pretty clear by my message and I think
that I will continue to condemn
apartheid and military occupation and
that in this moment I'm focused on
calling for an in genocide and calling
for an immediate
ceasefire so Jesse when did supporting
genocide become hip or cool on college
campuses and do you think they really
believe it or is this part of the
performance activism we talked about
that's a good question I don't know some
people look like they actually believe
it other people look misguided but you'd
have to sit them in a room and open
their heads up I did not like that it
was like a Batman symbol when you throw
that up on the air and and you're
basically saying we like ethnic
cleansers we like terrorism and if
you're a Jewish person and you're
walking around campus and you see that
proar bat signal go up it's the same
thing as having a swastika or if you're
an African-American student it's the
same thing as having a KKK thing
projected on there now I wouldn't expel
those students I'd say this is the first
strike you bring them in and you say you
do one more thing like this and you're
gone you bring a Jewish person and you
sit him across a table from and you say
this is how this makes us feel this is a
threat to violence when you put that up
there but this should be across theboard
judge and a lot of conservative students
now are saying how do you think we feel
you can't sometimes even go to a college
campus as a conservative and speak
without being assaulted they have to
hire private security
if you're Charlie Kirk and you want to
give a lecture on campus so they just
need an across theboard situation we're
going to protect women we're going to
protect women sororities from being
invaded and peeped we're going to
protect white males Straits we're going
to protect gays and lesbians we're going
to protect blacks and we're going to
protect everybody including Jewish
people and it has to be the same rules
for everybody it's called tolerance yeah
you know Piers many Elite universities
are not facing any kind of vot from the
donors but shouldn't they all be
thinking now about the fact that you
know this is the culmination of years of
almost an anti-American ideology and
obviously anti-Semitism well I love what
John hunman did at upen you know he
wrote he wrote the head a letter and
just said I'm out and that's by the way
I'm told tens and tens of millions of
dollars boom out the door and I think
there's got to be punishment at the
highest level financially like that from
the big donors who should not accept
this uh but I would actually kick these
students out I wouldn't give them one
chance if you if you basically endorse
terrorism terrorism by the way against
Americans uh killed Americans as well as
obviously 1400 uh Israelis if you kill
Americans and you're attending an
American University and you endorse the
terrorism that kill them you're out
that's it Zero Tolerance Because by the
way these people as you touched on when
it comes to free speech have zero
tolerance for anybody else that has any
view that deviates from theirs so apply
the same cancel culture logic that they
apply to everybody else about everything
to themselves because what they've done
is actually more heinous than anything
else I can think of in recent times you
know but you talk about where they're
getting this from they're getting it
from the people teaching them right
right you had this guy at Cornwell
Professor Russell rickford who said he
felt exhilarated and energized by the
terror attacks that's what he said in
public
had a megaphone right he's a professor
teaching these kids right another one at
Stockton accusing Israel of weaponizing
the Holocaust think about that think
about publicly accusing Israel of
weaponizing the Holocaust so they're
being taught by people who have
extremely warped and dangerous mindsets
so of course some of them are going to
Veer towards that mindset but I think
you kick them out and you say no and I
think to the donors you you can make the
call do what John Huntsman did actually
vote with your wallets take away the
funding for these places until the
people that run them create an
atmosphere where this kind of thing is
simply not tolerated you know it's
interesting Dana the way Pi sets it up
that you know the
anti-israel fervor is in addition to
that it is recognizing and cheering the
deaths of Americans who were in Israel
yeah they skipped over that part right
they just want they want to pretend like
that didn't exist and it also feels like
they like the young woman that was just
talking it feels like she learned some
talking points and she just repeats them
over and over again it's like like
there's no like wisdom in something that
she's saying she also said that losing
that her job was violence okay so like
they don't even know what the word
violence means I also want to point this
out that now that we have some Decades
of this problem the teaching of these
ideals the you know the Lancet magazine
that's like the oldest medical magazine
very prestigious so they organized a
letter signed by 2,000 medical
professionals calling for a ceasefire in
the region and then there's a note at
the bottom that they debated whether or
not to include a call to release the
hostages wow and they decided against
including it so imagine this you have
2,000 medical professionals expressing
concern over the hospital bombing that
did not happen and they decided as a
group voted to remove the call to rescue
the hostages that's
rot Greg you want to comment on the rot
yeah well you know I don't it's not this
is not a protest movement it's it's
hysteria you're witnessing a hysteria
it's a brainwashing effect when you look
at how the seeds were planted and
Amplified by the oppression filter you
talk about the sloganeering that's the
Linguistics of a hysteria using phrases
like decolonization you don't even have
to know what that means or resistance
calling uh calling uh terrorists resist
istance Fighters you know um but this
they they are targeting a very
susceptible group and that is American
college students because they live in a
plastic bubble they're like a Boy in the
Plastic Bubble I don't know if you
remember that movie so they're
completely cut off from outside
perspectives and they are they refuse
critical thinking because critical
thinking is kind of an absolute
philosophy it's it's obviously racist so
now they can believe that in anything
that you know a man is a woman a Jew is
a non Na and what they're trying to do
now and I is they're trying to create an
artificial Holocaust to cancel out the
real one I think that's what they're
doing because they're trying to take
away that power from the from the Jews
the irony is that Hillary I guess it was
a couple weeks ago claimed that Trump
supporters needed deprogramming when
it's actually large elements of the new
members of their party that are
suffering from really obvious
brainwashing when you're seeing it
around you can tell it's a virus that
it's that that it's all so emotional and
so nonsensical that it is an actual
contagion and it's a
hysteria the only way you can counter
this is through persuasion through
deprogramming talking to them and
showing them how they've been
manipulated by false information it's
the only way to do it you can't
deprogram us we're going to deprogram
you exactly Jesse got it and you know
what that explains why the there's such
a big differ between young people
supporting Israel and older people it's
it's the education system hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else